so we've been working in this playground
method I called mine filter playground
where we've been creating queries and
adding filters so that we can learn how
to build up queries now this method has
very hard wired values in it so for
example City equals Tokyo and in general
you want to have a bit more flexibility
you want to allow users to specify the
property values that they want to search
on that's okay though because we've only
been using this method for our own
purposes for learning the real method
that gets invoked by the show
conferences page is query conferences so
we already defined one implementation
for query conferences it's very simple
all it does is get all the conferences
so if we go over to the show conferences
page we see all the conferences that
have been created we could add a filter
here in the page for example search for
cities Chicago and then search but
actually our filter is going to be
ignored even though up here it tells us
that it use the filters because on the
back end it's calling query conferences
and the implementation of query
conferences gets all the conferences and
doesn't care about filters so what
you're going to be doing next is
updating query conferences so that it
does respond to the filters so there's a
few things that you're going to need to
do one is that you need to copy in the
conference query form Java file and put
it in the form package and then you're
going to need to change the signature of
query conferences so that it takes a
conference query form you're also going
to have to import the conference query
form then you need to update the
implementation of query conferences to
return the results of conference query
form get query so this is all you need
to do so you return conference query
form don't get query got list this will
actually work there's actually a fair
amount of code going on behind the
scenes in conference query form but if
you make these changes your filters will
start to work but let's take a look at
conference query form get query so you
understand what's going on there after
you copy conference query form over you
may find you need to refresh your
project before it actually shows up oh
there it is good so conference query
form has already been implemented in
full you don't need to implement
anything but I really encourage you to
read
it and understand what it does it checks
for inequality filters make sure that
there's only one inequality filter in it
it also checks if you have an inequality
filter to make sure that the sort orders
in the right order and add each filter
in turn constructs the query and returns
the query one other thing I want to
bring to your attention is this enum
here that defines the operators you see
eq is defined to be equal to equals and
we're going to see how that is used in
the api's Explorer so here we are on the
api's explorer we'll go to query
conferences now you see we have the
request body where we can add a property
and the property is filters then we add
a filter you keep clicking and adding
these things so let's add a property
filter on field but now we want to
filter on City equal something so we
need to specify the operator and
remember the enum listing operators
where eq was set to equals and now we
add the value that we want to check
against and we'll do London just because
I know we have some conferences in
London so this is how you specify the
filters here now let's execute it and
see if it's going to work oops cities
not right I think maybe it's supposed to
be capital C at this point so this is
defined in the conference query for
taking a quick look actually I should
have entered all capitals for the city
so i'll go back and do that again city
with a capital the operator defined as
eq and the value london this time we
find all the conference's whose city is
London there isn't that much code that
you need to change to get the show
conferences page to respect the filters
but there is actually quite a lot of
code going on in the conference query
form class that it would be good for you
to read through and understand now let's
take a look at what happened in the show
conferences page after we deploy the app
to app spot so here I went to the all
tab and we see all the conferences now
I'm going to add a filter and I want to
filter on max attendees
greater than a hundred add another
filter I just want to get the
conference's in February this search let
me run this query I fail to get the
conference's now if we run this same
query in the api's explorer and its max
attendees greater than 100 start month
is too cold and dark in February so we
want to find a nice conference to go to
and we execute and again we got an error
you see again it's the back end error
and this is because we actually don't
have a composite index to satisfy this
query so this is one danger of giving
the users a free hand in adding filters
in any way they want you need to be
really careful to make sure that all the
necessary composite indexes have been
created so now the query conferences
method can handle multiple filters but
there's still an optimization that you
could make to it see here that the query
result shows the organizers display name
well the display name must be
dynamically calculated for each
conference because he organizes display
name is not something restoring the
conference we dynamically calculate it
so let's look again at the query
conferences method so now I've changed
it a bit so that i get the ecole
conference query form get query which
returns me a list of the conference's
and then what i'm going to do is iterate
over each of the conference's figure out
the organizer for that conference and
then i'm going to preload all the
organizers and this is going to avoid
separate data store gets for each
conference because for each conference
we have to get the profile of the
organizer and then get the display name
after the profile so this is what the
final implementation of query
conferences would look like and you can
find this in the lesson 4 folder